on va se relaxer à présent avec cette
nouvelle séquence du 7-8 je reçois
françoise de la nied bonsoir à vous et
didier de gabelle bonsoir également on
va parler du tchi kong
on va définir tout d'abord c'est une
gymnastique traditionnelle chinoise
vous êtes enseignant justement comment
vous définiriez alors qu'ils se lancent
le chi kong
il faut d'abord expliquer peut-être le
terme quiconque seul hic chic ça veut
dire l'énergie est content ça signifie
le travail la voix donc on traduira par
le travail de l'énergie alors ça c'est
ni un art martial ma discipline de
compétition pas du tout pas du tout
c'est avant tout nous on appelle ça un
art énergétique chinois qui est en fait
qui est basée sur la médecine
traditionnelle chinoise
c'est à dire ils travaillent sur les
méridiens les points d'acupuncture
l'énergie qui circulent à travers ces
méridiens qu'on essaye de faire circuler
justement au moyen de l'exercice -
quelques images de ses différents
exercices par exemple comment se déroule
une séance on commence par se relaxer
ensuite il ya des mouvements très précis
à effectuer en fait on essaye de
provoqué une coupure avec le monde
extérieur avant de commencer donc par le
biais de d'automassage de d'étirements
qui sont doux pour préparer le corps les
chauffer avant de faire les exercices
que vous voyez si en apparence sont
simples mais dans la pratique de
sollicite énormément de corps dont elle
s'est exercée justement son sont très
écrit c'est très précis c'est oui elles
sont effectuées il ya des enchaînements
fait généralement de huit à douze
mouvement en fait parfois un peu plus
qui sont répétés chaque mouvement de 3 à
6 fois souvent mais ça dépend beaucoup
des enchaînements donc ce qui est
intéressant par rapport au taï chi chuan
par exemple qui lui un art martial mais
qui est très proche
c'est que en fait on a le temps de
s'installer dans chacun des mouvements
pour pouvoir le vivre en fait elles sont
les bienfaits ya des bienfaits pour le
corps sur les émotions sur
l'environnement sastre
il commence à bien faire d'abord je
pense assouplir les articulations
assouplir encore les temps non les
muscles dans un deuxième temps ça va
améliorer les systèmes fonctionnels du
corps puisqu'on travaille quand même sur
l'énergétique chinoise
ça va permettre aussi de relier ce le
haut et le bas du corps parce que quand
vous lever un bras il faut essayer de
sentir et c'est ce qui est très
difficile au début de sentir que quand
vous fait un bras effectivement
l'exercice va agir jusqu'en bas du corps
jusque qui est donc en fait au début des
exercices vont consister à détendre dans
un premier temps le corps pour pouvoir
dans la suite dont l'année ressentir un
peu ce qui se passe à l'intérieur ça
peut soulager certains mots à un mal de
dos par exemple ça peut la belgique qui
assure à le guérir mais l'apaiser ah oui
ça c'est sûr c'est sûr et certain
les gens viennent vous voir pourquoi
justement pour des pour des remèdes
comme ceci ou alors aussi pour évacuer
un stress qui est devenu très présents
aujourd'hui aussi dans la société aussi
un stress en fait et c'est vrai que là
avec la pratique
la difficulté est que les gens viennent
souvent juste au courant fait alors que
c'est une pratique qui doit se faire
tous les jours même cinq dix minutes et
pas forcément sur un enchaînement mais
un ou deux mouvements suffisent et à
terme au bout d'un certain temps
alors ça ça varie suivant les individus
de suivre leur sensibilité en fait au
fur et à mesure ils vont prendre une
distance par rapport au quotidien par
rapport aux agressions qu'on peut avoir
donc c'est vraiment pour moi c'est un
véritable outil antiste antistress et
qui m'a profondément changé au fil des
années vous y êtes revenu comment vous
par exemple j'étais toujours attiré par
le parc j'ai vu comme vous comme
d'autres personnes des reportages et
j'étais attiré par ces disciplines là et
un jour ça a mis du temps à venir en
fait en europe et moi j'ai commencé il
ya maintenant il ya d'ici 10 ans autour
de 10 ans et le jour où j'ai ma femme
dépassée dans un forum un voisin et puis
là il m'a dit l'indien court j'ai foncé
je me suis inscrit et j'ai démarré en
même temps tai-chi-chuan et puis les
pcci qu elle est bien faire ont été
immédiats non non non c'est pas vrai au
début disons qu'on il faut vraiment être
en soi écouter tout ce qui peut se
passer au niveau de son corps dans la
pratique des mouvements et au début on
est on est on des occidentaux on regarde
qu'est-ce qui fait celui-là est ce que
je fais comme ça est ce que je fais bien
etc
on y va quand même vers lte est en fait
le petit vélo qui tourne sans arrêt et
ça c'est pourtant c'est le but c'est
justement de l'arrêté d'être vraiment
dans l'expression du mouvement vous avez
commencé de quelle manière
chic on sait pas ce que j'avais des
problèmes aux lombaires j'ai bon donc je
me suis tourné vers cette pratique parce
que j'étais attirée c'est vrai déjà par
la médecine chinoise voulait savoir un
peu ce qu'était cette médecine je
voulais un peu en avoir des descriptions
un peu plus concret et donc je j'ai
suivi un enseignement pendant trois ans
donc au départ je n'avais pas du tout
pour enseigner en fait un c'est après je
me suis dit pourquoi pas miss comment ça
m'a apporté un bien-être
ac je serai pas à ces médias mais bon
aussi parce que quand on fait des
exercices de quiconque on les connaît
le bien-être se fait dans les cinq
minutes qui viennent surtout pour les
maux de dos ou dépôt du coup moi donc
c'est quand même assez c'est quand même
important et c'est intéressant même
temps alors c'est le chip ont justement
vous inscrire si vous voulez en savoir
plus il y aura c'est nationale des
journées nationales 19e journée du 3 au
9 juin l'occasion de s'essayer à cette
discipline
vous allez y participer est justement
vous avec l'amicale vietnamienne de
saint quentin où vous dispensez vos
cours va se traduire de quelle manière
il aura des cours gratuits des accès
sera complètement ouvert à qui veut
venir
il n'y a pas besoin de s'inscrire faut
juste renseigné éventuellement je sais
pas si vous allez communiqué les jours
et les alesi justement c'est l'occasion
je les connais pas par coeur le mardi en
fait de toutes façons à 19h30 de 19h30 à
21h en fait à l'école
erik satie s'activent le jeudi c'est à
s'agacer de 20h à 21h30 salle gauguin et
le dimanche
le 9 juin ça se passe qu'on l'espère
qu'il fera beau on fera ça à l'extérieur
dans le parc paul forme square paul fort
et ça change quelque chose de pratique
est justement le tchi kong en extérieur
on les ressentis sont complètement
différents c'est un une discipline qui
se pratique plus tôt dans la nature donc
nous avec notre température l'hiver
surtout celui qui doit qui dure c'est
s'est pas vraiment approprié mais dd qui
fait beau en fait on va plutôt
privilégier ma la pratique dehors à
l'extérieur plutôt qu'à l'intérieur
alors ces journées nationales seront
pilotées par une fédération qui existe
d'ailleurs depuis 1995 c'est une
pratique très encadrés ou pas le chicon
que justement comment on devient
enseignant professeur plusieurs écoles
sur le marché en fait anti on peut
parler de marché en fait mais ça les pod
dans le cas de certaines écoles on suit
une formation à raison d'un certain
nombre de week-end en fait pendant deux
ans aujourd'hui ces trois ans avec des
stages et à la fin on est diplômé de
l'école qui est reconnue de la
fédération ça ça ne permet pas de
d'enseignés ça permet d'enseigner de
façon non rémunéré si vous voulez être
rémunéré il faut passer à côté de ça un
diplôme d'état qui va vous permettre
d'exercer cette bicyclette enseignants à
quel titre vous avez suivi cette
formation
oui on à l'école du team et à eau pour
ma part et puis moi ces sites européens
de quiconque dans le sud de la france
est-ce qu'il faut régulièrement aussi
par se mettre à jour mais suivre est ce
qu'il ya une évolution est ce que la
pratique est la même depuis le début
depuis l'origine ou est-ce qu'il faut
évoluer aussi on évolue par la pression
et justement c'est l'expérience le temps
qui fait beaucoup pour sentir justement
l'énergie et pour justement pouvoir
transmettre parce qu'on peut pas
transmettre cet art si intérieurement
nous mêmes on ne ressent rien donc à la
fédération qui nous qui nous échappe au
temps et ont fait des stages une soeur
n'est ni ses stages pour nour cycle est
régulièrement on n'a pas encore eu aussi
beaucoup d élèves parce qu'en fait par
rapport à leurs difficultés mais obligés
de revoir notre pédagogie est assez
régulièrement et ça c'est très très
formaté l'essence est aussi important de
titres est il est aussi important que la
formation à la formation
déjà faut des années pour la digérer
parce qu'elle sait très très intenses en
fait même si c'est des week-ends ou
vous apprends des formes et des formes
qui sont des formes c'est des
enchaînements fait un appel aux chicons
et après faut vraiment le temps de pour
assimiler chaque forme il faut un temps
et ensuite pour l'enseigné c'est encore
autre chose que merci à tous les deux on
redonne les dates de ces journées
nationales du 3 au 9 juin l'amicale
vietnamienne de saint quentin il
participe
les cours seront en accès gratuit sur
les jours que vous avez mentionné mardi
jeudi et dimanche
les renseignements bien sûr auprès de
l'association merci à vous pour ceux qui
veulent en savoir un petit peu plus et
avant de poursuivre ce 7,8 justement je
vous propose de regarder ce reportage il
est signé de julich chasseresse et d'
anthony rech un reportage réalisé sur
l'un de vos cours
mouvement de tchi kong son temple où
l'enchaînement harmonieux quasi poétique
cette gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise associe gestuelle lente et
postures physiques respiration et
travail du souffle concentration et
conscience corporelle
elle requiert des principes de base et
l'enracinement la fluidité multi t du
corps le vide le plein le ying et le
yang
ces élèves en tenue décontractée
maîtrise les enchaînements et semble
ainsi hors du temps et juste après le
court je me sens en pleine forme j'ai
envie d'entreprendre plein de choses et
j'ai beaucoup récupéré je me sens
présent d'accord avec ce qu'ils mentent
aussi quand j'en ai besoin je le
pratique à la maison ou d'un nature et
en fait ça devient une hygiène de vie en
fait est un bonheur les visages comme
les corps apparaisse détendu paisible
cette discipline ancestrale plaît même
pour ses bienfaits sur certains mots
beaucoup de rigidité beaucoup de
problèmes de liaison entre les
différentes parties du corps beaucoup de
problèmes rhumatismaux on a la surprise
de voir des personnes arrivées
finalement très handicapée et en
quelques séances
on les voit réussir des exercices dont
on se demande si ce sont vraiment les
mêmes personnes qu'on avait vu quelques
semaines auparavant
les journées nationales du ti kong se
déroule du 3 au 9 juin
l'occasion de s'essayer à cette
discipline lors d'ateliers découverte
gratuit